[Music]
on this wednesday night the long-awaited
return of cross-border travel
the plan to lift restrictions at u.s
land and ferry borders to fully
vaccinated canadians it's been
incredibly confusing for travelers who
can't understand you know why is a
canadian can i fly to the united states
but i can't drive what to consider
before you hit the road know where
you're traveling to where you're
traveling from
state of emergency over a calories water
supply i feel like i live in a third
world country why residents in nunavut's
capital can't drink the tap water the
red tape that's left a former afghan
interpreter and his family stranded in
ukraine this is the only chance to save
my family what's holding up their
resettlement in canada plus transplant
transport the drone delivery in toronto
that's a world first and shatner's trip
to space
while the rocket trip moved the canadian
actor to tears
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with another sign things put on
hold because of the pandemic are
returning to normal thanks to vaccines
the us is lifting land border
restrictions it means fully vaccinated
canadians will again be allowed to enter
the united states at land and ferry
border crossings starting in early
november
canada has been open to fully vaccinated
americans for more than two months in
our top story tonight jackson proskow
looks at why the biden administration
took so long to reciprocate and whether
it will be back to business as usual
570 days after the doors slammed shut on
non-essential travel there's a plan to
fully reopen the world's longest border
to anyone who's vaccinated it's
incredibly important because it's been
incredibly confusing for travelers who
can't understand you know why as a
canadian can i fly to the united states
but i can't drive beginning in november
the u.s will reciprocate a decision made
by canada in august lifting restrictions
on land travel for foreigners who've had
the jab
come january essential workers like
truck drivers and nurses will also have
to be vaccinated to cross but there's
still a wide gulf between the two
countries over standards
travelers arriving at the u s border
will simply be asked if they're
vaccinated they may only have to provide
proof if they're sent for secondary
inspection and unlike visitors to canada
u.s bound travelers will not need a
negative covid test across the border i
think it's very unfortunate that we
didn't align our way out of the pandemic
as we sort of aligned our way going into
the border restrictions because it is
going to be more confusing for travelers
one two three one big question will the
u.s welcome canadians who received mixed
doses of vaccines the white house says
that decision is up to the cdc
the deputy prime minister visiting
washington says it's a concern we are
working to clarify and finalize all the
details with our american partners the
lack of clarity comes after months of
delays the explosive spread of the delta
variant and lagging u.s vaccination
rates derailed plans for a summer
reopening the free flow of trade and air
travel also dampened the urgency i think
this border should have been opened
five months ago
because the same criteria applies today
as it did then if you're vaccinated you
have strong immunity from giving or
getting coveted ultimately the fate of
canadian travelers at the land border is
being tied to u.s policies for visitors
from every single country on earth that
november day when the border reopens
will be the same day that a new u.s
mandatory vaccination policy goes into
effect for all travelers arriving in
this country by air
i'm sean o'shea niagara falls ontario
border communities have been waiting for
this for more than a year and a half
those used to traveling back and forth
between the two countries say it's about
time
in this canadian city known for
attracting tourists from around the
world the mostly closed border with the
united states has hit the community hard
niagara falls new york and niagara falls
canada one big city so i've got family
on both sides friends on both sides we
go shopping back and forth it's a real
symbiotic relationship with canadians
soon allowed to drive to the united
states again for non-essential travel
many are hoping for a return to normal
it's a great idea i have friends there
that i want to visit so it's a great
idea joanne arpino was a canadian living
in michigan she had her first child
during the pandemic and it was the first
grandchild in our family it was my first
baby i had a daughter and so my dad
lives in canada which he actually only
lives 27 minutes from my house but
across the border and so he wasn't able
to come over to see her in places like
these it's common for someone to live on
one side of the border and work on the
other colin mcdonald lives in windsor
works in advertising in detroit he
hasn't been there in a year and a half
we would still find ourselves crossing
over on the weekends for sports
entertainment restaurants really
anything new that was going on land
borders reopened to american travelers
in august but not the other way around
businesses have paid a high price we've
seen a huge drop in revenues
at you know places like the duty-free
stores along the border but also with
accommodations hard on tourism hard on
relationships in places like these the
period of time that border communities
would like to put in the past lives have
been cut off and disrupted it's had a
major impact on people the changes come
in time for u.s thanksgiving the
christmas holiday period and winter when
tens of thousands of canadians typically
head south for warmer weather donna
all right sean o'shea and niagara falls
tonight thank you canada's public safety
minister released a statement saying the
government welcomes the news of the u.s
land border reopening though bill blair
urged canadians to continue to take
precautions and follow public health
advice when traveling outside the
country as david aiken reports the
official guidance from health canada is
still to avoid non-essential travel
we still have travel advisories in place
recommending that people don't travel
unless it's absolutely necessary in
other words even though you can maybe
you shouldn't i think it's really
important for canadians to listen
closely to the advice from
phac from canadian medical authorities
and to just be careful and the rule
change in washington does not change a
key rule set by ottawa all fully
vaccinated travelers returning to canada
from the u.s whether it's by plane train
or automobile must still have a clean
pcr test before returning one reason for
that the public health risk continues to
exist particularly for travelers to u.s
states which still have severe covet
outbreaks and or much lower vaccination
rates than in most parts of canada we
need to be cautious and and we need to
exercise prudence uh in terms of
traveling to places where
uh kobe 19 is still um
in in you know spreading white you know
quite you know intensely
and some regions in canada especially in
alberta and saskatchewan have health
systems already under stress because of
high case counts they do not need sick
travelers i think that is why we sort of
say that it is important to exercise
quite a bit of caution
know where you're traveling to where
you're traveling from
still continuing to loosen border travel
restrictions with the u.s is seen as
crucial for revitalizing business
relationships and strengthening the
economy on both sides of the border i
think in any business relationship the
critical ingredient is trust and trust
is difficult to earn
over the over a camera you really want
to be there in person and so i think
businesses in particular are going to
lead that charge
still business groups and health experts
say there is lots of work still to do on
international travel everything from
setting a vaccine passport standard to
how countries recognize different
vaccines and that means there will
continue to be pressure on governments
in both washington and ottawa for even
more clarity on travel rules donna
all right david aiken in ottawa thank
you a major water crisis is unfolding in
a canadian capital city iqaluit has
declared a state of emergency after
finding evidence of gasoline in its
treated tap water nearly 9 000 people in
the capital of nunavut have been told
not to drink or cook with water from the
tap even if it's filtered or boiled as
nithu garcia reports that's left
residents scrambling to find clean water
this is what happens with no access to
clean drinking water a mother and child
sourcing water from a river with no
drinkable tap water across ecallute
residents like connie nowdluck are
scared the fact that this happened here
in ocala in a major city in canada in
2021 is very disturbing she says for
nearly two weeks people here complained
about the smell of fuel or oil in the
water but we're told by city officials
it was safe to drink until tuesday why
wait so late
and people are getting sick people are
getting headaches the mayor says his
team trusted scientific monitoring and
shares the same frustration now targeted
at him i've been drinking the water
myself my kids have been drinking the
water um you know it's a of course it's
worrisome so you know i i wholeheartedly
understand where the public is coming
from an investigation is underway to
determine the cause we don't know how
much is in there what's in there if
there's anything there the smell is in
there of course meanwhile stores are
running out of bottled water prices
already high have surged one store
actually ran out of
bottled water in two hours all of the
caluit's drinking water comes from a
single source the lake geraldine
reservoir which has been fraught with
supply issues partly because of reduced
rainfall in recent years in 2018 it
spurred a health emergency after that a
pump was installed to divert water from
another river to lake geraldine but now
with possible chemical contamination
affecting the entire city's supply
residents have been gathering water to
boil from a third source
the mostly inuit city of nearly 9 000 is
just the latest indigenous community in
canada to deal with water contamination
issues and residents like nowdluck say
ottawa's lack of action sends a
devastating message because we're
indigenous
it doesn't really matter there's boil
water advisories all over the country in
indigenous communities for over 35 years
in some places
in a statement the federal government
said in part it's continuing to
collaborate with all partners including
the city to ensure residents have access
to safe drinking water as soon as
possible i feel like i live in a third
world country
it's really sad to say i really legit
feel like i live in another country at
this moment that we're not priority
nintu garcia global news
quebec is delaying the deadline for
health care workers to be vaccinated
until november 15th the health minister
says the potential departure of up to
fourteen thousand employees is just too
big a risk for the already strained
system
we want to give the unvaccinated staff
extra time
to collect their dose
but i wanna be clear
we will apply the mandatory vaccination
for healthcare workers
but postponing the 30-day deadline
is the best solution under the
circumstances
starting next monday all unvaccinated
employees in the public health sector in
quebec will have to be tested at least
three times a week before their shift
all new hires in the public system will
also have to be vaccinated quebec had
imposed a friday deadline for all health
care workers to be vaccinated or face
suspension without pay
several ontario hospitals are making
vaccinations mandatory for visitors not
just staff starting october 22nd the
university health network in toronto
will ask visitors for proof of full
vaccination a negative covid test will
not be accepted in lieu there are some
exceptions those visiting some pediatric
patients or people at the end of life
will not need to show proof of
vaccination
today ontario reported its lowest daily
case count since the beginning of august
306 new infections it is a significant
drop from the 458 new cases confirmed on
monday the last time ontario logged a
daily case count this low was on august
the 5th
there is some breaking news tonight
about the soldier who was set to lead
canada's army lieutenant general trevor
kadu has become the latest high-ranking
officer to face a military police
investigation the department of national
defense has confirmed the canadian
forces national investigations service
is investigating historical allegations
against kadya sources tell global news
they are sexual in nature cadyu's change
of command ceremony was postponed last
month to allow the investigation to take
place in a statement kejia denies the
allegations but says they must be
thoroughly investigated
canada criticized renate acting faster
to help afghan refugees coming up the
bureaucratic backlog and the agonizing
wait for a man who worked as a canadian
forces interpreter
canada plans to welcome 40 000 afghans
saying there's a moral imperative to do
right by the people of that country and
more than 13 000 applications have been
filed according to the immigration
department it says staff are working
hard to process them but the wait is
agonizing crystal gomencing met with one
family now stuck in ukraine and spoke to
a former government employee who says
it's taken too long to help those who
helped us
served as an interpreter for canadian
soldiers on the front lines in
afghanistan from 2009 to june 2011 he
was a part of the canadian mission to
help win the hearts and minds of locals
i have certificates with me i have
letters with me that there are many
canadians commanders high-ranking
peoples they clearly says that this is
the person who saved my life
if javid was not there i would be not
alive here now one of hakmal's platoon
commanders from his days as an
interpreter calls him a brother in arms
it's been hell of a ride for him to to
get out because he followed all the
requirement for canada
process jeremy vavil set up a gofundme
page to ease the family's burden
hakmal filed his family's application to
move to canada under the special
immigration program on july 28th just
days after it was unveiled
immigration refugees and citizenship
canada says it's continuing to process
applications for afghan refugees day and
night adding we have mobilized our
entire global network to process visas
and issue them on an urgent basis
until they're officially accepted by the
canadian government they're not eligible
for any canadian supports but they're
not eligible for any ukrainian services
either because they're not claiming
asylum in this country leaving them to
fend for themselves which means relying
on donations from friends and strangers
at the end of august there were two
families who were rescued by ukrainian
special forces it was really dangerous
while it was the globe and male who got
them out of kabul it was staffed from
the office of the liberal mp for thunder
bay rainey river marcus palowsky who
took up an initial collection and
flewjavid his wife and kids out of
kandahar when the taliban moved in i
know for a fact there were people in the
minister's office who cared a lot and
really wanted to help still robertson
obama says more accountability is needed
he no longer works in the mp's office
but says he started collecting names of
afghans who worked for canadian soldiers
in 2019
he says the government could have acted
faster i would love for there to be an
investigation maybe a committee report a
study something to find out what
happened i don't think that's ever going
to happen but it would just be great to
know like who's responsible and for them
to take accountability there's no other
other chance this is the only chance to
save my family
the malls in the meantime are just
hoping more months won't pass with them
sitting in ukraine
crystal gamansen global news
keefe
still ahead a raging fire shuts down a
major highway in california and forces
hundreds to flee
[Music]
a raging wildfires threatening homes
northwest of los angeles the alisal
wildfire has scorched almost 6 200
hectares in california's santa barbara
county and is just 5 percent contained
hundreds of people have fled their homes
and exxon mobil facility is being
closely monitored and a major highway
has been closed the fire is being fanned
by fierce sundowner winds that are
common in the area and have stoked some
of california's worst fires
early on wednesday hurricane pamela hit
mexico's pacific coast the resort city
of mazatlan was drenched with heavy rain
causing flash flooding at the height of
the storm wind gusts hit about 120
kilometers an hour pamela is expected to
be less intense as it moves inland
moving northeast into the u.s it's
likely to reach the texas border by
thursday
heading to the real final frontier next
william shatner makes space history
this newly released video shows what's
believed to be the world's first
delivery of donor lungs by an unmanned
drone the predawn flight took off from
toronto western hospital and six minutes
later touched down at toronto general
hospital it was a collaboration between
the city's university health network and
a quebec bioengineering company
logistics and time are huge factors in
organ transplants and drones could be
the future
well playing the captain of a starship
and actually going to the edge of space
are two radically different things today
canadian actor william shatner
discovered that firsthand his trip on
the blue origin rocket lasted just 11
minutes but it was enough to move him to
tears ross lord reports
[Music]
as a promotion for commercial space
tourism you could see this flight coming
from light years away a star passenger
whose name is synonymous with outer
space william shatner
space
a final frontier shatner starred in the
classic star trek tv and movie franchise
confronting villains no matter how
dangerous
i have five times your strength
no match for me
but defeating fictional bad guys pales
in comparison to this challenge flying
106 kilometers high for real at the age
of 90. a prospect he'd only entertained
previously for fun
and i think it's gonna be a long long
time
the touchdown brings me around again
and here comes our crew back into the
desert
doubters consider these flights a
crashed display of wealth and power by
people like amazon founder jeff bezos
who made this one possible
but for shatner and three other
passengers the effect is beyond
overwhelming
captain kirk himself the great william
shatner what you have given me
is the most profound experience
i can announce
i'm so
filled with emotion about what just
happened the jeopardy the the the
the
moment
you see how
the vulnerability
of everything it's so small
this air which is keeping us alive
is thinner than your skin a man known
for an abundant ego during his acting
career has been humbled i hope that i
can
maintain what i feel now i don't want to
lose it
infinite awe and wonder after this final
frontier
ross lord global news from one actor
pushing the envelope to another being
featured on them canada post is honoring
christopher plummer with a commemorative
stamp it features images of the
toronto-born actor on stage and in films
from prospero in the tempest at the
stratford festival to captain george von
trapp in the sound of music back in
1965. canada post says it consulted
plummer about creating a stamp before he
died and he was thrilled with the idea
he passed away in february at the age of
91.
and that is global national for this
wednesday i'm donna friesen tonight's
year of canada is this field of pumpkins
at a farm in wolfville nova scotia there
are beautiful spots all over canada
please email yours to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
bye-bye
[Music]